imagine you're in a forest in the middle
of nowhere there's no Wi-Fi cell phone
service or any way to communicate with
the outside world there's not much you
can do about it until now SpaceX has
been launching StarLink satellites into
orbit since 2019
it's Elon Musk's ambitious project to
provide high-speed Internet anywhere
even to the most remote locations in the
world the goal is to connect the planet
by delivering Internet to places where
it's unreliable expensive or just not
available
but StarLink is also being created for
another reason there's a bigger purpose
behind it which I'll get to at the end
of this video so how exactly does
StarLink work SpaceX is using its Falcon
9 rocket to launch about 60 Stirling
satellites at a time the satellites are
stacked on top of each other in put in
the capsule those Starling satellites
are separating from second stage right
in front of you right now the satellites
are placed at a relatively low altitude
in space because the closer you are to
earth the lower the latency latency
refers to how much time it takes for a
signal to travel to its destination and
back so low latency gives you a higher
internet speed Stirling speed will be
good enough for competitive gaming it's
targeting a latency of less than 20
milliseconds that's faster than cable
internet in paragould - what you'd get
with fiber-optic broadband 1,000
satellites will be enough for basic
service but SpaceX wants to get 12,000
of these satellites into orbit as of
June 13 2020 SpaceX has launched 540 the
company has actually applied for
permission to launch up to 42,000
satellites although it's not guaranteed
that they'll actually launch that money
why so many because the satellites are
so much closer to earth they cannot be
stationary they have to move faster to
maintain their orbit they'll cover a
smaller area so more satellites are
required for internet coverage
everywhere
what SpaceX is trying to achieve is
unprecedented
about 9,000 satellites have ever been
launched in all of history out of those
9,000 about 5,000 are in orbit in less
than half are actually in use in
comparisons StarLink will be a
ridiculously large satellite
constellation but with that comes
concerns scientists are worried about
light pollution because of how much
closer the satellites are to earth they
are bright enough to see without a
telescope SpaceX has been trying to
address the issue the latest batch it
launched had a sunshade that can block
reflections of sunlight off the antenna
StarLink is controlled on earth with a
device about the size of a pizza box the
terminal will look like a round UFO on a
stick and it'll be easy to use there are
two instructions plug-in socket point at
Sky but it's not so simple for those who
live in countries where the internet is
censored one of the most famous examples
is the Great Firewall of China where
Facebook Twitter Instagram YouTube and
YouTube zone or Google are all banned
star links internet access cannot be
controlled by national governments
because it does not rely on domestic
communications infrastructure but a
government that censors the internet
will probably ban the Starlin device
like most things that are banned it will
be impossible to confiscate them all but
countries can also try to jam the
satellite signals or take it one step
further
Elon once said this about what China
could do
[Music]
let's not forget elands other company
Tesla has a lot invested in China there
is a huge customer base there as well as
the Giga factory in Shanghai StarLink
hopes to begin service in North America
first starting with the northern US and
Canada in 2020 and then expanding
coverage to nearly everywhere in the
world by 2021 if you live in a large
city StarLink is not necessarily going
to replace your internet provider
sterlink is not intended to be used in
high density areas because it doesn't
have sufficient bandwidth the focus is
on reaching places that don't have
coverage or where coverage is weak
SpaceX does have competition in the
space internet race but it's also ahead
of the game the company is at an
advantage because it owns its own
rockets and the Rockets are reusable
they land back on earth that is key
because it significantly brings down the
cost of each launch the British startup
one web was a competitor but earlier
this year it filed for bankruptcy
Amazon's project kuiper also wants to
bring you high-speed Internet from space
its CEO Jeff Bezos is the owner of Blue
Origin which is also developing reusable
rockets SpaceX has not said how much the
Starlin service will cost as of the
publishing of this video but this is
meant to generate a lot of revenue for
the company SpaceX estimates StarLink
will eventually bring in 30 billion
dollars a year that's about 10 times
more than the annual revenue it expects
from its core rocket launch business so
at the beginning of the video I talked
about how there's a bigger purpose for
the creation of StarLink the bigger goal
is this the revenue from StarLink will
be used to support Ilan's greatest
ambition I can't emphasize this enough
this is the thing that we need to do we
must make life sustainably multiplet
multiplanetary StarLink will help fund
the development of a city on mars there
are also plans to use the satellite
system on the Red Planet - so StarLink
is not just a standalone project it's a
piece of a puzzle leading to a larger
goal it's not an end but a means to an
end that end is civilization on another
planet
I hope you enjoyed that video about
sterling hey guys I'm Cindy pom the
creator of news think if you liked what
you saw give us a like and don't forget
to subscribe to our new channel I'm
gonna be doing a lot more video it's on
topics that I find super interesting so
I hope you'll join me along this ride
see you soon